welcome back everybody I am so excited
to have our next guest here she is an
incredible singing vent triloquist my
son is obsessed with vrism now he loves
her um and she plays the role of
Gabrielle on Sesame Street he is a
Pioneer in the world of funk music and
is considered one of the greatest basist
of all time together they recently sorry
Joe um together they recently dropped a
a children's album called spaceships and
dreams give it up for Megan pipus and
booty
Collins
[Music]
[Applause]
look up
[Music]
for I love it I love it um so wait this
I have to lead with this first of all
welcome to the show welcome back and
welcome to the show in general such a
legend thank you for coming to hang with
us oh this is awesome I have to know how
y'all know each
other well actually uh we're homies yeah
you know we're from the same okay so how
long like how did this happen so um I
was born and raised in Cincinnati and
booty is a Cincinnati native he doesn't
know this story but I actually learned
about
booy oh my God love to learn about that
on television I learned about Bootsie in
the third grade okay we had a project
where we had to figure out which
celebrities we shared birthday with
birthdays with so my birthday is October
26th so I share a birthday with boy
Collins and Hillary Clinton oh that's
amazing and I'm just finding that out
too there is there is power in that
that's amazing and I never forgot that
detail and but I never thought that I
would actually get to work on music with
him yeah but I remember it we had the
same birthday wow so how did y'all meet
up for this though how did this end up
how did y'all connect for this yeah so
we met for the first time in 2015
through a mutual friend a friend showed
one of my videos of doing puppetry and
singing to him and Bootsie loves
characters obviously and and voices and
he invited me to his Studio to just try
out different songs and voices and we
stayed in touch since then that's so
cool inspired by each other's creativity
I love that so uh Megan's puppet
actually interviewed you right
oh was it Jumba is that baby Jumba baby
Jumba he's a killer he's a
killer I love him so much and he liked
the interview so much he was dying
through the interview right yeah that's
my little cousin baby junbug he's a
5-year-old rapping baby who aspires to
be a producer just like Bootsie so and
you never know what's coming out of his
mouth next you know which makes it more
fun yes yeah well since you said that is
it can we get June bug out here cuz I we
can let's get him one out baby Jun here
we go baby June
buug my god there he is there he is
what's up baby jumo hey hey how you
doing hey everybody I'm baby
jumo what's up what's up hi Miss KY
hello so you inspired this did you know
that baby Jumba oh I did is that what n
mama told you uhhuh yes exactly you are
inspiring and you're you're creating
creativity I like it I'm creating
creativity and music mhm exactly which
connects everybody I love that so wait I
have to ask you something real quick you
is it two and five your kids are yeah
they're GNA be five and three oh my God
yeah her kids are
old so do you test music out on them oh
yeah I test music out on them all the
time yeah but usually she has to get me
to do it yeah that's yeah that's very
true so I I I'll read read books to them
play songs for them and they'll be like
yeah this is kind of cool but Megan um
mommy can you go get June buug oh
they're like they don't want yeah I'm
the cool one you're the cool one you're
probably the better judge you're the one
who really oh yeah I'm the hype man I
get things
going hey do you so you I hear you have
a lot of great kids right yes so wait do
they like this do they enjoy doing love
it actually you know they wanted to be
in it I mean you know all the time it's
like you know we can't do it like that
y'all you know my kids are the same way
right now they're like can we come and
be on stage I'm like well not every time
that might be weird but yeah but it is
kind of cool that they're inspired by
what you're doing and they're like
excited about it well their part for me
you know like the young ones are like
the part of the whole thing they make
you want to do something to yeah you
know to lift lift not only them up but
lift everybody up I mean when they come
they like bring the party with them
yeah Doom bug shows up he brings the
party I'm a little
hurt my mama said that I'm your 11th
grandchild yes you are you he got 11th
Grand he got 11 grandchildren okay
that's a li start playing me today yes
thank you
thank so wait so let's talk about the
song that y'all are going to be
performing today it's called make you
proud right yes okay so what's obviously
you want to make people proud yeah okay
so the name is songs make you proud and
it's all about pride and honor not just
of our children trying to make us proud
but also as parents making our kids
proud yeah I want to make you proud yeah
M my mama said that if I make you proud
today Uncle Dy is going to take me to
the toy
store getting getting free gifts I like
it I like it are you you're in the
performance as well right oh yeah sing I
just W to make you I just W to make you
thank get with that
V all right everybody here's their video
for Make You Proud from their new
children's album spaceships and dreams
give it up for Megan pyus and Bootsy
[Music]
Collins I've always wanted to sing on
The Kelly Clarkson show Dr roll for your
wildest Wow Let's Go
Junebug 5 6 seven eight
I just want to make you I just want to
make you proud make you proud proud of
just want you to
be just want you to
be just want you to be so proud of
me your eyes are a
mirror an
adventure
wonder your are like a time machine I
look something I've never seen your
future is more than I could
dream your
reflection shows everything I need my
sweetling all I know I just want to make
you proud of
me I just want to make you I just want
to make you make you make you proud
proud of
me
[Music]
proud just want you to
be just want you to
be
proud you're doing so good Babble for
real you think so yeah now it's time to
Funk It Up 5 6 s
it
[Music]
out a man may I mess up the dance that's
okay I'm still proud of you you know
[Music]
why do to stop me from Ling
you thank
NOAB you can
[Music]
do I just want to make you I just want
to make you proud make you proud proud
proud of me of me
yeah me make you proud of
me
[Music]
one more time y'all let's hear it from
Megan Pipers and vti Collins their new
album spous and dreams is out now we'll
be right back with what I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
liking thank you guys have a great night
I'm going
home